Oh can I be married to the most
successful supermodel in the world I
think it would be much more fun to be
the supermodel you get to travel and
then you have to eat people to kind of
change the flipside the downside to that
no I feel like the agent would be better
for your psyche but maybe the
supermodels but if your bank account
maybe maybe not maybe the agent I would
say most successful supermodel because I
love that side of things so all goes
yeah our model yeah I'll take the
supermodel superhero sure isn't it the
same thing ah I feel like flying is
pretty unbeatable invisibility kind of
that sounds very cool you like that I'll
go as superhero yeah what about the
super model superhero
I like the future
I'll do the 16 1996 for sure maybe 96
oh gosh 1996 I think that would I yeah I
would want to travel anywhere I want
yeah I would travel everywhere I want
and then my kids would say stop and my
wife and I would go back to the mansion
oh gosh I guess probably Li cuz I like
to be grounded in one place I would
travel
oh my got trip and we're gonna throw up
oh my god
that would yeah that would be very
intense throw up
that's what bears are see that's a
staple on trips it's easy trip is easy
you'll make a name for yourself really
true runway because I've done it once
and it was like such an adrenaline rush
that came with it
I'd say photo shoot okay you let in my
eggs or Elan my man ah okay
would you is that just just a question
yeah I'm a size medium because if I'm
under models who are men they're doing
very well yeah but life is not fun as a
guy